en tribune cet après midi les supporters
assurent le spectacle
mais c'est bien sur le terrain que sont
les stars du ballon rond ou plutôt les
stars en devenir
d'un côté ryanair kamali 18 ans milieu
relayeur de l'ue et sow un profil de
passeur et un style de jeu portait sur
l'organisation du collectif
le jeune joueur arrivé du tours fc cet
été a connu récemment une première
sélection en équipe de france des moins
de 18 ans le travail qu'il faut j'ai la
chance d'être entouré de super personne
qui est qui me permettent de déposer mes
qualités au dessus et c'est vrai que
c'est une réelle chance de pourrait
évoluer si de l'autre côté un joueur de
19 ans un peu plus expérimentés et xm
hassan l'ailier droit de châteauroux
compte déjà plusieurs caps dans les
sélections jeunes de l'équipe de france
il a même déjà joué une vingtaine de
minutes en pro un match de ligue 2 face
à grenoble en septembre dernier
je suis un joueur qui aime me provoquer
alors la balle dribble et voilà percuter
éliminer qui aime bien faire du jeu
j'aime bien voir le ballon voilà combiné
après avoir parfois c'est mon défaut
peut-être un peu trop en faire parfois
après seulement je suis comme ça mais je
travaille au quotidien pour l'améliorer
accélération dribble passe millimétrée
durant les 90 minutes les deux joueurs
montre toute l'étendue de leur talent
objectif la victoire bien entendu mais
pas seulement
la coupe gambardella est une compétition
prestigieuse pour les jeunes footballeur
c'est l'opportunité de se montrer pour
attirer l'oeil des grands clubs mais
attention à l'excès dgo il faut leur
faire justement en comprendre que c'est
pas forcément le but de jouer tout seul
de se montrer parce que on sait qu'il ya
des gens autour que la bombarde et là ça
fait parler etc
mais c'est les résultats de l'équipe en
fait qui font que ça va attirer
l'attention pour le résultat c'est
châteauroux qui l'emportent sur orléans
1 0 sur cette frappe croisée les
berrichons 2 se hisse en quarts de
finale ils connaîtront leur adversaire
jeudi prochain